[Music]
i've known you for quite a long time yes
uh 20 years oh my god that's true yeah
yeah and uh i'm i'm curious about your
dating life because uh you've been in
many different relationships yes time
that i've known you keep trying and i
will i worry about you are you is it
going well right now well there's
nothing to worry about right now i have
a i have a girlfriend she seems to have
moved in
and uh
she made it sound like she came in
through the window well it wasn't uh
momentous it was sort of like i guess
all your stuff's here you know it was
that kind of thing yeah and uh it's
going well she's significantly younger
than me which uh really don't judge and
don't you judge either people
i am tired of people judging older guys
with younger women as if they're creepy
or weird look if there's no law against
dating someone emotionally 15.
number one
and number two i'm not going through a
midlife crisis i don't know what it is
i'm just attracting younger women right
now i'm not a predator i'm just not
why are you laughing at that yeah yeah
don't
you don't want to go around saying i am
not a predator
i think older guys who date younger
women they get this bad rap and i'm just
attracting young women i'm not
attracting age-appropriate women right
now thank god and i um you know
oh well well look
paint the picture for me what is she
like well yeah i've never been with i
love her a lot because i you know
frankly i'm terrified of her and uh
you're scared of her yeah i never
realized that was important it's very
important when you love somebody to be
just terrified i mean how else are you
gonna behave right you know what i mean
yeah yeah she she pretty much laid it
out right when i met her she said look i
know you're a comedian you're on the
road a lot i just want you to know that
if you screw anybody out there i'm going
to screw people you know
she said that to you and and i and i
said that worked that that worked i
understand exactly right that's a i mean
that's so upfront of her but also that's
such a specific threat i will sleep with
people you know and thank god i'm old
enough not to go who are you talking
about i mean are you talking about like
a headliner or a feature act i mean you
know where in the order are they going
to come because it would be a comedian
yeah they're all comics i'm like you're
not going to screw an open mic because i
couldn't handle that you know what i
mean
that's that's the way i hierarchy of
comedians you want it to at least be
something yeah yeah you know someone
famous so i go oh okay that guy is funny
so um
but
but it's you know look she's younger
i've been through this before you know
my uh my second wife yeah i've had to uh
you know was much younger than me and i
know what's going on i'm just trying to
sort of you know break the the pattern
yeah i literally at the beginning of
this thing i i really considered having
business cards printed up that just said
marc maron a phase you're going through
you would give that to women
resolving daddy issues since 1999
[Laughter]
look
what well i'm just curious you
what a nice attitude
yeah what do you want from me i'm
answering the question you're on a
freaking
okay i like that what yeah what does the
host want i haven't told you enough
it's difficult conan i'm trying the best
i can